uh we can probably go ahead and start
people may still come but that's okay
okay so
hey everybody and welcome to the third
day
of the bootcamp if i'm counting right
and today the great pleasure to
introduce
sambas the person
who is behind a lot of proof theory from
this
proof complexity proof theory bounded
arithmetic
and a few other things that you probably
don't know that you contributed to
but in particular in our area
uh sam's work had been groundbreaking in
number of places
in uh proof complexity in particular
some of the main results uh
some of the main conjectures that's
spurred a lot of work they do to some
such as the first uh proof the digital
principle can be done in fragger
all the papers talking about
about things should be hard and which
things should be easy with
uh maria banan and tony pitasi
and i think by now some already showed
that pretty much everything they
proposed to be hard is
actually doable and um
my first introduction to the area was
sam's beautiful
uh lecture notes on proof
complexity-bounded arithmetic
and he has written several book chapters
very nice and very readable on um
proof complexity starting from his
famous bounded arithmetic book which
actually started the whole field of
bounded arithmetic
to upcoming chapter in the handbook
of satisfiability with yakub nordstrom
if you've done also groundbreaking work
in complexity
in particular given an algorithm
for the formula evaluation
problem in nc1
on top of that um if you ever need to
write
proofs in your paper the later class bus
proofs have been a lifesaver not only
for me but for other people
for the long time that sam wrote
if from what i say now you think that
sam is
only doing theory and is far from
practical check out his google scholar
and you'll find on the very top of his
citation a number of papers and graphics
sam actually had also been doing very
interesting work on the full things
graphics
and i think the second edition of his
textbook
basis the software for it that some
wrote
is upcoming okay without further ado
some this is yours
all right thank you for the very nice
introduction a pleasure to be
here virtually not actually here i wish
we were together but it's
good we can get together online um
so i guess we should just get started um
i want to say first of all if you want
to look at the slides for my talk
they're available
online already if you go to the chat
window there's a url for them so you can
look ahead or back in my talk if you
wish
and do feel free to stop me with
questions along the way
i if no one asks questions we'll be done
extra early so i'm hoping people will
ask questions and discuss as we go
uh some if you don't mind reposting the
slides because i think people who came
late might not
see the link if they it should be in the
chat window history i could redo it
i assume that people see the um
the history of the chat but okay it's
there now at any rate
um so for those of you who went to
armin's talk yesterday
i was watching there's actually a fair
amount of overlap between what he did
and what i'll talk about for the first
half of my talk so
i'll do it from a different point of
view but nonetheless uh
i didn't uh
i was slightly well to see what should i
say was
we're gonna we're gonna overlap a fair
amount of the talk so we'll see how it
goes but anyway
let me start off with background
material the satisfiability problem i
think everyone knows that's the name of
our program but of course the notation
is we have
an instance of satisfiability is a set
of clauses a set of clauses
the clause is a disjunction of literals
a literal is a variable or a or a
negated variable
as such this represents a set of clauses
represents a conjunctival form formula
and so the satisfiability problem is the
problem of showing
either that the set of formulas is
unsatisfiable or
finding a satisfying assignment
now of course finding a satisfying
assignment if you manage to do it you
can
you don't have to you can just show that
something satisfiable by
giving the values in the in the truth
assignment
and it's easy to check that it's a
satisfying assignment uh show
something's unsatisfiable
of course is or to provide a witness
that something is unsatisfiable is
harder
this is more of a co-np kind of problem
but
one way to show unsatisfiable is to find
some kind of
refutation in particular in practice
we're often using
cdcl solvers so let me
mention that cdl solvers are based on
resolution and again i think everyone
knows what resolution is
it's a refutation system for clauses or
you can think of as a proof system for
disjunctive normal
form formulas with the only rule of
inference is the
resolution rule as shown here from x or
c and from not x or d you can infer
c or d and the goal is to get a
derivation of the empty clause
um but since the resolution rule
preserves
uh truth under uh
under under truth assignments that is to
say if the two hypotheses of the rule
are true under some assignment than the
conclusion is
and if you can derive faults from the
clauses then there is no satisfying
assignment
to this and as everyone knows resolution
is sound and complete
as a reputation system so now i want to
get into cdcl so if you watched my
pre-recorded videos the slides were here
this this is taken from one of the
slides but i've changed the number four
to five here the
second line so cdcl sat solvers are
built on
on now saying five principle five
principal components the new one here is
back jumping
uh but the five components then are
dpl which is a depth first uh
search procedure for refutations and
i'll
talk about this in the next slides unit
propagation
guides the dpl search and also has the
big advantage of underpinning clause
learning
clause learning is infers new clauses
that
uh help prune the search space um
and then there's two types of backing up
there's
when you're doing a depth first search
you can of course could just back one
step in the usual sort of
process of adept first search but for
cdl cdcl
we're constantly doing back jumping or
non-chronological backtracking
that backs up multiple stages of the
depth first
uh depth first traversal to a point
where a learned clause is asserting and
i'll talk about this as we go along
and then restarts are sort of the
ultimate in back jumping you totally
interrupt the depth first search
and start a complete new search
um and there's many many more
optimizations on top of this
uh some of them just things like how to
choose decision literals other things
how to throw away
uh learned clauses as armand mentioned
last time
as you learn clauses you also constantly
throw clauses away
just because your run time tends to be
quadratic in the number of clauses that
you have
um anyway we'll let's do some more so
let's start off with the dpl procedure
it's named after the famous papers of
davis putnam and davis lodgeman
loveland from the early 60s
the input is a set of clauses
and the goal is to either produce a
satisfying assignment for the clauses or
a refutation of the clauses
and we do this in the basic dpl
algorithm just by a straightforward
depth first search
through the space of truth assignments
uh maintaining a partial truth
assignment
setting literals one by one to either
true or to true
and whenever you hit a hit hit a dead
end and you falsified some clause you
backtrack
and split the value of the last variable
and continue
and you end up either fully traversing
the tree in which case the
set is unsatisfiable or you find a
satisfying assignment in which case
you're done with showing it satisfiable
so unit propagation is the following
uh thing suppose you have clause c
and the partial truth assignment row has
has
assigned all but one of the literals in
c to false
then it's immediately clear that any
satisfying assignment extending row must
also
must set the remaining literal and c
true and so dpl with unit propagation is
the same as dpl
but in fact you carry out all possible
unit unit propagations
whenever as soon as you can
and uh i have a recursive procedure on
the next slide for this so let me
explain this
the algorithm is as follows you
initialize row to be the empty partial
truth assignment
you call the following recursive
procedure
okay so the recursive procedure does the
following we save a copy of row in row
zero this is
so when we backtrack we have a copy of
row we extend row by unit propagation
for
as long as possible so that means we if
there's any variables that get set by
by by unit propagation we do so setting
some variables by unit propagation may
trigger other variables that need to be
set by unit propagation so we do that
and once that's done we check whether
row falsifies some clause of gamma
if so we restore we back up by setting
row back to the saved
copy row 0 and return false
if rows already satisfies gamma by
setting
at least one literal true in each clause
we have a satisfying assignment or even
a satisfying partial assignment we can
stop the procedure
otherwise we pick some new decision
literal is called x
we set it true we call the procedure
recursively
and if that returns it did not find a
truth assignment extending row
so then we revise the truth assignment
row to set x false
and we again call the procedure
recursively and otherwise we backtrack
we return faults to back out of this and
if the top level returns false then we
know the
set of clauses was unsatisfiable
okay so this is all very simple i think
everyone's seen this before
but then now we get to conflict directed
clause learning
um so cdcl algorithms form the core of
most of the modern successful sense
solvers
that goes back to the early 90s or mid
mid 90s
and the underlying idea is that as
you're doing a dpl
search especially a dpl with unit
propagation search you
you look for when you when you're about
to backtrack you falsify the clause and
we'll call that a con
conflict and then we'll use
that we'll look at the way the clause
was falsified by unit propagation and we
use that to
derive a learned clause as i mentioned
in
earlier recorded talks it uses trivial
resolution and i'll draw a picture of
that on the screens a little bit but we
will just focus directly on the cdcm
learning part of things
these learn clauses are saved with gamma
and are then used to help guide future
proof search
in particular the learn clauses help
prune the search space in fact reducing
the needs to
re-traverse the same area of the search
space
um i think that's a fair statement if
there's experts online they might
disagree with me but uh i think that's
the main benefit of this
and an important feature of the way
clauses are learned
is that the learn clauses take into
account uh
exactly which literals were used to
obtain the con conflict
so that they ignore decision variables
that might have been branched on not and
not actually used and so this means that
the use of learn clauses helps to
compensate for poor choices of decision
literals
so we don't really know ahead of time
what's going to be good good decision a
little or not but the learn clauses sort
of help picked out
which ones were the useful decision
literals and focus in on those
um and one thing i want to mention here
in particular
is fast backtracking or back jumping
allows backtracking
past the decision literals that did not
participate in the clause learning
so that's an important feature here um
and that goes sort of hand in hand to my
mind with doing restarts but
we'll come to that later on in the
presentation
okay so here is the overall algorithm
for the cdcl
procedure it's not a recursive procedure
unlike the previous one so it's just a
loop
and the reason it's not recursive is
because we're learning clauses
so it's not like we need to pass data
back from from the recursive call
so we maintain a so-called decision
level and the decision level is the
number of decision variables that have
been set
we start off with the empty assignment
row and then the loop does the following
some of this looks very familiar extend
row by unit propagation for as long as
possible
just as in dpl if that satisfies gamma
we're done we return row as a satisfying
assignment
if it falsifies some clause then now i
need to backtrack so first of all if
we're at level 0 then it's just
unsatisfiable
because it's based on no just no
decision literals at all
and then optionally we learn one or more
clauses c
and add them to gamma and then we choose
a back jumping level
l prime less than the current level
l we unassign all the literal set at
levels greater than l prime
we set l to l prime and then we're going
to
continue the loop on the other hand if
row
neither satisfies gamma nor falsify some
clause of gamma remember the else
statement down here
can people see my mouse on the screen by
the way i think you can
the little small plus sign there um
otherwise we pick some new decision
literal that has
some little x hasn't been set yet we
ain't we
we increment the level and we extend row
to set x
true and then we continue with the next
iteration of the loop right
so of course continuing with the next
iteration of loop means we're going to
then immediately do
unit propagation for as long as possible
okay so that's the basic cdcl algorithm
so let me clarify a little bit more of
what's going on here about the learn
clauses because that's the crucial part
so here's the typical properties of
learn clause
there's a single learn clause c
so-called first uip
uh unique implication point clause
armin talked about these yesterday and
i'll draw a picture on the next screen
as well
but we usually learn a single learn
clause and
we have that gamma one implies c
and what that means that is not that
it means the following it means that if
we take the
assignment that falsifies all the
literals in c
and that's sigma to be that assignment
and if we hit gamma with that assignment
sigma which means that
sigma sets some literals to values
we set those literals to those values in
gamma
any clause that's made true is discarded
any
and any uh otherwise any any little
that's made false in a clause
is just is just is is just removed and
then we look at
whether unit propagation from gamma
restricted by a sigma
implies the empty clause
if it does then we say gamma 1 implies c
and this has a couple terminologies in
the literature
c is inferred by reverse unit
propagation
which is a term coined by van gelder or
c is an asymmetric tautology which um
armavir and his his uh his co-authors
coined that phrase
um but this is the general way
when we learn a clause it typically
follows by this it's one implied by the
the set gamma the other really crucial
property is that c
is asserting so all literals
in the newly learned clause c are false
in the current partial assignment row
and by that i mean before you do the
backtracking there's one literal that's
set at
some level little l
uh the remaining literals are set at
lower levels
um so what i mean by being set at a
level is you look at the
value of that variable capital l
whatever value that was when the
variable was said is the level
and so namely and to get some notation
here there's a
level little l prime which is the second
level of the literals in the clause so
there's one
one literal at the level
little l there's at least one literal at
the level
little l prime and the rest of the
literals are at level little l prime
or lower so now we backtrack well the
first thing to notice is that because
the
literal set level l is set to false
but it needs to now be made true we have
to backtrack to below level little l
right so whatever backtrack level we go
to that's the capital l prime
too many l's on my slide i'm sorry about
that capital l prime it has to be less
than
little l and the common choice is
usually to backtrack to level
l prime is little l prime and i'm going
to use the terminology in this talk
the fast fact tracking means that
actually we
went back more than one level so that l
prime
capital l prime is less than capital l
minus one
so that means you've backtracked not
just from the from the
current decision level back one step but
back multiple levels
okay and
here's the picture of a conflict graph
and first uip learning
so let's see what's going on here in the
picture over on the left side
and again i hope let me actually
highlight things to make sure you can
see that here
there's a decision literal x which i
drew in a square box to show it's a
decision literally let's set up
this level capital l and then there's
clauses like
x implies so x and
a imply z which so a was set at a lower
level
previous to the current level and
there's a clause
here x bar or a or z
which allows us to set z by unit
propagation
and then there's a clause x bar or z bar
or y
that lets us set y by unit propagation
and then this process continues until
eventually
we have the clause um
oh let's see v bar w bar
c bar which should be some place on
ot bar where it's on here some place i
hope
um t oh t v w
here it is t bar v bar
w bar these three things
imply falsity so we get a contradiction
that way by just just just using unit
propagation repeatedly
now the so-called first uip
clause is why because when you look at
the things that are set at this decision
level
why is the why by itself with things at
lower decision
levels is enough to imply falsity
so the learn clause here we look at this
cut this hyphen
this dashed line is the cut we look at
the edges
crossing that cut that's the from the y
the a
the b and the c and then our learn
clause is
a bar or b bar or c bar y bar
and so this is an asserting thing y is
set at the top level
a b and c are set at low at lower levels
and something i'll come back to is
clause minimization is
based on self subsumption can actually
learn the smaller clause
a bar or b bar or y bar because um
because of the fact that we have um
let's see it should be we've got the
clause
w is inferred from
sorry c c is inferred here a bar b bar
a bar or b bar or c so this allows us we
can resolve the learn clause with that
clause
to get a or a bar or b bar
or y bar and this is a simple example of
self-subsumption
and then the point here is that in this
picture i've lost all my
other there on the previous slide by
backtracking to the maximum decision
level of abc
the learn clause a bar b bar c bar
becomes asserting
which means that y bar can be inferred
by unit propagation
so we backtrack that at least unsets y
and of course everything else at level l
this could then trigger further unit
propagation
and that further unit propagation could
force without any more decision literals
could force an additional round of of
could force another
conflict and force another backtracking
to occur
and in particular it may be that this
ends up we end up with the new level l
prime
capital l prime is less than l minus one
so it may be forced upon us it may be
completely forced upon us the cdcl
solver can't avoid it
because you have to go back more than
one level possibly after two rounds of
conflicts
okay
again i'm i'm delighted to get questions
even if you feel like
you don't know the stuff pretty well and
just want some clarification i don't
want just questions from in other words
if you're not expert and want to ask
questions that's also great too
you can either speak up or pop something
in the chat window
so just to clarify one thing uh to make
sure i understand
so the unique implication point uh there
is always at least one
because the decision variable is is one
of them right
yes that's correct so there's always a
unique
unique implication point in this case
there's two here there's two
implication points there's the y
x is another candidate but it's not a
unique one
i mean it's not it's not it's not the
first one
they're they're both they're both unique
you know implication points but
why is the first one and x is the second
one and these sort of make
sort of natural break points because of
the asserting property i mean there's
lots of other
places we could have done breaks we
could have done uh
you know we could have made it here
and that would just replace y bar y with
t bar and u bar
right um uh
so we could have put it really lots of
places i think in some sense
this seems to be the this is the common
choice
and because it um
because it uh gives us the asserting
property
and uh oh there's a comment here
i think you can back jump after a single
conflict and
uh caramel uh karen goes ahead to add
also back jump after one conflict
so yes that's absolutely correct but
it's not actually
necessary after the first conflict to
back jump more than one level
cdcl does always do that i think but the
framework isn't completely necessary
it's just necessary to unset the
asserted literal
and there's some argument to be made
that maybe there's a disadvantage to
back
back jumping i don't think that's true
in practice but it's at least
not opportunity true true that it's
always good to back jump
because one of the most time consuming
parts of cdcl is the unit propagation
just because if you have a lot of
learned clauses it may take but you know
it takes a lot of time to
do you to do to do unit propagation so
by back jumping if you back jump
excessively
you lose your stack of recently unit
propagated variables
and potentially that's that work might
be completely redone i mean it could
certainly happen you back jump a lot of
levels
you set something at lower level but
that has no effect whatsoever
and then you redo all the work of unit
propagation
that you just backtracked over so that
could certainly happen in principle
but in practice cdcl solvers already
backtrack more than one level
so some one question and one comment
can you hear me yes hi hi vijay yes uh
so
the question was do we understand why
first uip
is you know empirically we know first
erp is the best
class learning scheme uh do you know
do we know why oh okay good question so
i mean i can tell you some some
guidelines for this
so if you took the it's not true in this
picture here but
let me draw it suppose there had been
yet another variable here
um if i can do this suppose there was
another variable here d
from a lower level that had been used as
a hypothesis for c
for z if you took the cut here
you would have also d as one of the
literals in the clause from the lower
level
so if you took the cut at a second uip
or the last uip
you would you would get you could you
potentially get more
literals from lower levels and hence
more lower levels involved in the clause
and one of the criteria that people use
for goodness of clauses is that they
uh how many levels the so-called glue
value
the number of levels of literals in the
learn clause
is a measure of the usefulness of
learning that clause
and so if nothing else going back to
second uip or last uip
you're at some some bit of a
disadvantage because you're using more
and more
levels in your learned clauses
the other question had to do with you
mentioned
that it's not clear that
back jumping always helps and uh
there is this paper i think was in 2018
or actually the tool
that i believe one had a medal in
the exact competition where they did not
perform
back jumping all the time
and only backtracked some other time
although i don't recall exactly
how they made the decision whether or
not to back jump or backtrack
um right but any but but perhaps you're
suggesting something stronger is
that you're saying you don't may not
you have to backtrack you have to do one
decision undo one decision right so to
correct at least one decision
yes um then you're suggesting
and then you may want to do one level
backtrack and then
continue the different path that will
save you the work that you did in terms
of
the unit propagation um in some cases
that might actually be better than
back jumping uh to earlier levels
yes exactly um i think in practice that
doesn't seem to happen but in principle
it could right
yeah yeah so uh sybil actually uh put
the paper there
chronological backtracking right oh yeah
from just two years ago very good yeah
there's a question also
there is a question uh victor would you
like to speak or should they
sure i can uh yes uh so
this this may uh so are there properties
of
cnf that uh that make it
more likely that that learn clauses will
significantly help i mean can you
can you is there something easily that
you could sort of look at the cnf and
say okay i should be
really aggressive and learn clauses or
not so aggressive or
so on ah
yeah i don't know i don't know of any
specific properties that would say this
perhaps others can speak to this um
let me yeah let me just ask a sort of
counter question
imagine two different approaches to
trying to
attack a problem you could either try to
choose decision literals that
are as likely to satisfy the formula for
instance you might
look for decision literals that when set
true set as many clauses true as
possible
or decision literals that trigger as
many uh unit propagations as possible
and
these are both mentioned in the
literature as methods right
the other thing you might try to do is
it's almost the
alternate thing is choose decision
literals that
immediately or as soon as possible
trigger a conflict
right so in some sense one the first two
things i suggested would be trying to
satisfy you're sort of working to
satisfy the clause
the set set of clauses the second method
would be your you're trying to learn
clauses to drive more consequences of
the clauses
and i don't know whether there's any
real
concrete thoughts about which of those
two approaches is better
but but but basically i don't know the
answer to your question so us
okay can i offer something on this
this is that's correct the way i see it
is that
um we're assuming that these decision
uh choices are arbitrary and so
the conflict learning is kind of
adaptively tries to uh fix you know
these
perhaps uh inappropriate decisions
and so what you learned basically is
dependent on what decisions you've made
and if you didn't do that then you would
never
undo the uh the error if you will of uh
of
a bad decision right
that's how we view it as a kind of an
adaptive way of
fixing you know bad choices yeah no
karen yeah karen has an excellent point
um learning the clauses avoids the bad
choices but you also want to
get the bad choices out of the queue out
of the stack
right so so it's later on there probably
will be good good choices if you're
right right yeah so
okay good all right um well if i may add
just one point
to the question that victor raised um
the answer is we well we don't quite
know the answer
as the original question was what's the
property of
cnn formulas or what class of
xenoformulas
lend themselves to uh be
uh effectively solved in this way right
can we characterize that clause
uh in a proper way and and we don't have
a
proper characterization as yet and
coming to
uh karam's point that's uh i totally
agree with that point
um as to why uh conflict classic
learning is so useful is that it also
guides the branching heuristic
another way to say what karam was saying
right for sure
yeah that's good okay yeah sorry for the
noise there you apparently
triggered the uh thing from a company
started with a g that must not be named
to start making music when he spoke
okay uh all right
there's another paper on chronological
cdcl in the chat window as well
okay okay so then um
so moving on so here's basically i don't
have to say too much about this this is
just the change
to the algorithm i had on the previous
page i think we had a lot of discussion
the only changes are
uh we now learn an asserting clause and
we choose a back jumping level
compatible with the asserting clause and
the other the other comment i want to
stress is that even if you
don't even if you do chronological cdcl
you still can be forced to backtrack
multiple levels to
unset and reset the asserted little to
change the value of an asserted
asserted literal so even with
chronological
ccl you do sometimes have to backtrack
multiple levels
okay so restarts
uh restart backtracks the cdcl proof
search back to level zero that's capital
l prime equals zero where no decision
literals have been
set sorry about the missing word maybe
i'll
fix that on my own online slides
um and uh learned clauses can be
maintained
after restart um i am not i might even
touch on garbage collection or
clause clause clause reduction
uh but let's just and but nonetheless
it's
perhaps surprisingly restarts are
extremely effective in the practical use
of cdcl
sat solvers i wouldn't say it's
surprising that they're effective but
the fact they're extremely effective
is the surprising part perhaps and but
we can actually give a nice
proof complexity characterization of
cdcl with restarts
so one direction basically cdcl plus
restarts
is equivalent to resolution meaning the
following that
if there's a resolution proof of some
length
of k then there's a cdcl plus restarts
run
of length polynomial in the length of
the resolution
refutation and conversely if there's a
cdcl plus restarts run that has
run time k there's a resolution
refutation of size polynomial in k
so the fact that resolution can piece
simulate cdcl plus restarts is just the
fact that all learn clauses are inferred
by reverse
unit propagation hands can be derived by
re
resolution at the very end we're just
running a straight dpll algorithm and
that can be done by tree-like resolution
so all that together just gives us a
resolution refutation
so the converse holds also and i wanted
to um sketch a bit of the proof of this
um so this is due to
peapod's sawat darwish and
at serious fixed it's early building on
my earlier ideas of beam counts and sam
cyberwall uh cdcl plus restarts can
piece simulate resolution though
the warning or the the uh the uh the
caveat is that the cdcl plus restarts
must make the correct choices to
simulate resolution
um these can be determined by looking at
the res
at the resolution refutation so it is a
so-called p simulation which means
there's a polynomial time construction
that takes the resolution refutation and
gives you how the cdcl
algorithm should run but that doesn't
mean you can do this in practice without
knowing the cdcl
algorithm ahead of time and in fact if p
is not equal to np resolution is not
even automatizable so that wouldn't be
possible
so here's the proof construction
so again we're going to take a
resolution refutation
and turn it into the run of a cdcl
solver with restarts
so we assume that the resolution
refutation
contains in order the clauses c1 c2 c3
etc
ends up with the empty clause so we want
to build a cdcl plus restarts
reputation of gamma and the general idea
is to let the algorithm learn
successively for i equals 1 then 2 then
3 etc
each of the clauses ci but we
don't know how to do this
and so the learning is a little bit too
strong
of a condition so instead we're going to
get a slightly weaker condition that
works that power
achieves the same effect we let the cdcl
learn clauses enlarging the set gamma so
that for each ci
we first get that gamma 1 implies ci
and then secondly after that we we
enlarge gamma again
to get the gamma absorbs ci
so absorbs is defined here
absorb ci so gamma absorbs across c
is means the following so c has literals
x1 through xk
that's the disjunction of them and it's
absorbed provided if you take any one of
those
literals x i and you set all the other
xj's to false then there's a unit
propagation from gamma
and those settings to xj's to false
either of x i or
of the empty clause so
to understand this might say let's
understand what this is good for
what's the point of learning the clause
c if we learn the clause c
we've learned x1 or x2 or xk
and what good does it do is to learn
that clause well it means that when we
do unit propagation
we can infer if we set all the one of
those literals to false
then unit propagation makes the other
literal true
so absorbing just says that although
maybe we haven't learned the clause
itself
we've learned enough to make that unit
propagation hold
and that's true except that maybe
instead of getting the literal x
i we get the empty clause instead
okay so this is what absorbing does for
us so absorbing is like the you know the
the poor nephew of learning but it's
good enough for us right
okay so so now then we want to prove the
following
lemma one is very easy if
we if first of all if a clause c is in
gamma
then it's one implied by gamma that's
absorbed by gamma that's just trivial
and the other is that if gamma absorbs
c no sorry sorry i've got right if gam
absorbs both
x or c and x bar or d
then it one implies they're resolvent
in other words if from x or c and from x
bar or d we've inferred
c or d and if x or c is absorbed and
x bar or d is absorbed then the
conclusion is one implied by gamma
and this is pretty easy to check just a
very simple check
we can't conclude immediately that c or
d is absorbed that's what we would like
to have
but this doesn't work if c and d share a
common literal
so it doesn't doesn't follow in that
case it's again easy to see that
so instead we have to do a little bit of
learning so if gamma
1 implies c then
cdcl can learn some more clauses such
that
forming a larger set gamma star such
that gamma star absorbs c
and then we'll take gamma star as the
new gamma and keep going
and so the idea being putting level one
and level two together we just
chug our way through the proof first one
implying
every clause in the in the res in the
resolution reputation and then absorbing
every clause in the in the in the
resolution refutation
so these two lemmas give us the uh
the theorem uh modulo size bounds which
will be clear when we do the
construction so we just need to do
the proof of lemma two so the proof of
lemma two
um let's take our clause we assume it's
one implied by gamma
if it's not absorbed say with the last
variable xk
choose the decision literals to be in
the order x bar 1
x bar 2 up through x bar k and we're
going to keep that in that order
even as we run and backtrack we'll
always keep setting them back in that
same order
and we run cdcl learning clauses putting
them into gamma
and then backtracking if any decision
little follows by
unit propagation the earlier ones we can
just skip it
now if after setting
the first eye of the clauses
the unit propagation either gives us
falsity an empty clause
or xk or even some any xj
for j less than k we're done that's
enough to make c
be absorbed with respect to x k
otherwise when we reach
once we've set all of those decision
literals x bar 1 through x bar k
we get a conflict because there's
because gamma 1 1 implies c
when we get a conflict it's a cdcl style
conflict
so some literal z is asserted in the
learned clause
and you can see z can't be an x j or an
x j bar
for j less than k so z must be a unit
propagation
consequence of x bar one through x bar k
minus one
and then the other thing to notice just
not hard to see that these
z's we repeat this process and each time
we get a z
it's a newly asserted literal and
they're all distinct once we've got one
z is a unit prop a
a unit propagation of the first k minus
one decision
literals it won't come up
as an assertive as a certain literal
again
so these newly asserted literals must be
distinct so
this last the second case the second
bullet point there
can happen only once per variable so
each
each variable can be one of these z's
only once so the process has to stop
with absorbing
c after most n
iterations where n is the number of
variables
and then we repeat this procedure for
each literal and c until c has been
absorbed with respect to each
of its member literals xj
so that's the so that's the proof um
i'm probably breaking the rules of math
talks by putting two proofs in the talk
so this is only the first one but
let's be might as well understand it
so where did i use restart so at the end
of the second bullet point
um we got an asserted literal z
so we had to backtrack to that point so
that meant we re unset
some of these x i bars z becomes
asserted
and then we you know we unset say back
to x i bar
and then we reset we again use x i bar
as a decision literal
and start again
paul did that make sense um i have to
say paul i think i first learned this
proof from your paper with cyberwall
so i hope it makes sense since it's
inspired by what you wrote
okay good thanks sam
yes could you um articulate what the
difference is between uh
the cyber wall bean proof and uh
the a serious and darvish proofs you
said there was they built on this
previous work
and i'm trying to understand what oh so
wait wait are you talking about
this proof or the uh
oh yeah yeah what was different here was
the difference
i lost it um oh yeah so the bean cow
saver wall they're the uh side
there um there they the um
you know what was the difference sorry
i haven't looked at this in years let me
think um yeah
uh
i'm sorry i'm blanking on this um
there was an analogous result in being
cat sets out several wall there um
oh yeah paul beam just said we didn't
use an asserting scheme oh they didn't
use this sir
okay good they didn't use an asserting
scheme good yeah the point is so these
the the more recent works from 2011
directly built on the
c cdcl as i described it with asserting
right right
okay
yeah there's another result similar in
that same paper
uh which okay anyway all right
okay um so this is this is the
construction rather simple construction
but also hard
hard to think of i think as well right
and non-subtle
um and uh
but it does give us the equivalence now
cdcl plus restarts with red with
uh with with resolution okay
um so then what about cdcl approve
search without
restarts i'm going to fix my slides up
here
um so there's a couple approaches to
this so let me mention the first one and
then i'll
also talk about the second without any
proofs and then the second one so
we we want us for this um we'd like to
we sort of suspect there's a separation
although who knows
and for this we wanted to prove
something like this we need to formalize
cdcl without restarts as a particular
proof system a particular formalization
of cdcl without restarts
and there's a couple of these in the
literature pool resolution of van gelder
and reg wrti of uh hoffman johansson
myself
let me just talk about pool resolution
because it's much easier to describe
a pool resolution refutation is a
resolution reputation that when
viewed as a dag admits a depth first
regular traversal so i'll say this in
words i'll show you a picture also so
that first traversal you certainly know
what that is a depth first
regular traversal means that on any path
downward in the door upward either way
think about it in the tree
you don't in the in the traversal you
don't
resolve on the same literal twice
so that's what regular means and then um
so here's a picture pool resolution
reputation so here we can do a traversal
so we can start at the
start at the root we here's a resolution
on the variable x we're going to
traverse this way
here's a variable on the resolut on the
variable z we sort of go
here backtrack to here and here's a
resolution on the variable y we go to
here
to here now we're going to backtrack
all the way to here
right so we're backtracking out and now
we resolve
on y and we traverse to here
now we don't traverse this this would be
a resolve on um
on z but we don't have to re-traverse
the part we've already traversed there
so we don't go across that
instead we only go up here
and well
they get the idea in here right and so
we
if we had traversed past this red line
we would have resolved twice on
y on the path because the proof is not
regret
not right not regular but the traversal
is regular
right okay and so the idea with pool
resolution is that once you've traversed
a clause it becomes a learned clause
this is not quite fit the cdcl scheme
but that's the idea nonetheless for pool
pool resolution
and then the question would be
does pool resolution can you simulate
pool resolute can you separate
pool resolution from cdcl plus restarts
or from full resolution
still an open question uh so this
approach hasn't yet reached fruition
but there is another result which i
wanted to mention
actually actually first well yeah
before i get to that first i want to
mention some drawback of using reg wrti
and pool red resolution is that
most modern cdcl solvers infer clauses
that do not fit within the framework
of either pool resolution or reg wrti
and we saw this earlier with the
self-subsumption
inference the self-assumption entrance
so first of all this is a resolution
reference where the conclusion is a
subclause of one of the
hypotheses and it's very common for
self-assumption
to be used to during clause learning
to simplify clauses and i i think armin
mentioned is talk something he says like
20 of the clause times you do learning
you get some self subsumption
um in my own experiments i've seen more
like 10 or 12 percent but
you know it's that sort of range pretty
high level of self subsumption
succeeds it's quite surprising and
cdcl solvers do this on the fly self
self subsumption which
performed on all the clauses which well
i left a bit here
it's performed on clauses in which all
literals have been assigned some value
and typically it's performed on all the
clauses that participate
in forming the learned clause
okay so these do not
fit the pool resolution greg wrti
because they resolve
on variables that have already been
assigned
and aren't backtracked past okay
so that's not part of the pool you know
it doesn't fit in the pool rep pool
resolution rag wrti framework
so the question so an alternate question
then would be does cdcl without restarts
but with
self-subsuming clauses which
participated in unit propagation with
self-consuming resolution on clauses
which participated in
in unit propagation does that
polynomially simulate rather
resolution and then maybe a further
question would be you could
carry this further and not just consider
self-subsuming but also consider
any kind of resolution on clauses which
participated
in the clause learning process for
instance
if you allowed that kind of resolutions
would that polynomially simulate
general resolution so this might
actually be a more
relevant question if you're asking about
the cdcl without restarts
simulate resolution um both questions
are though seem very interesting
as far as i know no one's looked at this
question before so i thought i'd throw
it out there
and just to give another example here of
self-subsuming resolution
if you look at this example from the
previous slide
these two clauses could have been
resolved to give
x or z my self's assuming resolution
maybe i can
my handwriting is not very good with
mouse but i can try anyway
it's one thing zoom is doing for us it's
getting better at drawing with mice
right this is subsume this subsumes one
of its hypotheses x or y bar or z so
it's an example
okay
okay
um one more topic before i wanted to
take a break if you guys will bear with
me for another
five minutes or so for the break are
there questions here though
so um the underlying assumption you make
when you pose this question
is that uh cdcl without restarts
possibly is a different proof system i
mean in in other words
restarts the presence of restarts
affects proof size
but it's also possible that restarts are
relevant from a proof search perspective
and not necessarily a proof
size perspective
true so yeah so if you were to change
the question
um even without necessarily resolving
the proof
size question there is a relevant
question from a proof
search perspective and
that's also worth pursuing okay
yeah i like that question so let me
rephrase it slightly what about cdcl
without restarts is it
automatizable can you find
probably not but can you prove that you
can't
automatize cdcl without restarts i don't
think that would follow from any known
results
no i don't think it is i don't believe
it is automatizable but it could be that
for restricted classes of formulas it
might be and for
these restricted classes of formulas the
difference between cdcl without
restarts and with restarts that from an
automatizability perspective
they would essentially be the same that
if you could
what the run of one could be simulated
normally by the run of the other from
from a search perspective
but i i haven't explored this question
but we do have a paper in
2020 on restarts that doesn't go to the
the the final question that you have
posed here
but it does answer some of the questions
in different
uh settings of cdcl
for example with randomized
branching etc so we have different
configurations if you will
so let me put it this way
you could take the solver and you could
switch on and off different heuristics
and you get different configurations and
for each
such class of configurations each such
pair of configurations
you could pose whether or not they're
equally powerful
or is there a way to separate them
and so the question about restarts can
be
thought of in a more general way what if
i for example
what's the difference between say vcs
and
non-deterministic branching so can i
or randomize branching can i have a
class of instances where
which separate the two
okay so actually you mentioned a paper
you might drop a link to it in the
chat window uh yeah it will do okay
there is another question um
yes so ah okay it works
uh yeah i was wondering if there is an
interpretation of
in processing techniques or like a
viable elimination in terms of strengths
of
what what you can derive
um yeah i haven't talked about in
processing at all here and so that's
in processing really breaks the pool
resolution
framework so it definitely doesn't fit
here um depending on the strength you
allow on in processing i mean since in
processing can do
introducing variables by extension in
principle you could get
full extended resolution um maybe but
there might be some
fragments of in processing that are uh
more
more interesting to to think about the
proof complexity of
but extended extended resolution of
course is a very strong system stronger
than
reagan and so forth or well at least as
strong as freight that's open whether
it's actually stronger
so yeah i think in in processing
some of those things follow from are
simulatable by resolution and some are
not i guess
so that can make a much stronger system
even things like pure literals aren't
really
simulatable by resolution right so with
you can't
if you have a pure pure literal it
doesn't mean you can infer it what you
can prove with pure
pure literals is that if you have a
proof in which you've set some if you
have a cdcl
say with with say with restarts but at
some places that set pure
pure literals true you can show that
there's still
a polynomial ref uh simulation of that
by resolution
because basically the setting the pure
little is true doesn't do anything to
the length of the res
of the resolution refutation um
so some in processing things are sort of
not harmful as far as proof complexity
goes and some of them are extremely
powerful
thank you okay okay um
so antonina is okay if i go for five or
ten more minutes
before the break um sure yeah
okay i just wanted to okay good so i
mentioned the
the other result here i'll go a little
maybe a little quicker on this one is
that cdcl without restarts does
so-called effectively
p simulate resolution so an effective
piece simulation means you're allowed to
transform a formula f
and the idea is the transformation
shouldn't really change the meaning of
the formula
but it might make it easier to prove in
the system nonetheless
in this case we're going to take the
formula f and take its c
its disjunction with a satisfiable
formula involving completely different
variables
so the constructions here is um
we're given a c f formula f x and n
variables
of x that has a reputation of size k
we're going to find a suitable
satisfiable cnf formula g
sub n in different variables y
completely distinct set of variables
and the g sub n of y depends only on the
number
n of variables not on f or k
and then we want to show that f x
or g sub n of y has a cdcl refutation
without restarts of size k
to the ob1 and this construction works
for cdcl solvers that really use the
usual methods of assertive learning and
backtracking
and this proof is due to uh beam and
savverwall
14 building on earlier techniques
especially close perhaps to hertel
bacchus potassium
van gelder from 08
but here it is
it fits on one slide so we assume we
have the following
a cdcl plus restart solver
s1 so it's using restarts that refuse f
x
it's following some execution path e sub
1
that has most k to the c restarts
so why k to the c well because we're
trying to simulate
resolution but that means that can be
converted to a cdcl plus restarts
scheme with the most polynomially many
restarts
we can also assume k is only
exponentially big just to be a little
sloppy on the constants less than 2 to
the 2n
and i'm taking k to be the number of
symbols in the resolution refutation
uh choose g sub n of y to be a
satisfiable formula
such there's some execution e2
of the cdcl solver s2
oh i should have said here explicitly
it's not a cdcl plus restart solver it's
just cdcl without restarts
and it finds gn to be satisfiable
right but it fastback tracks a lot of
times
fast backtracks at least two to the at
least at least k squared
i'm sorry at least k k to the c many
times so it backtracks at least as many
times
as f as s1 restarts
um okay so then a cdcl reputation
without restarts of f4 gm
just repeats the following loop uh we're
going to alternately
run the same simulation e2 trying to
satisfy gm
with the sim with the cdcl solver plus
restarts at
uh run e e1 that's
false that's showing f to be
unsatisfiable
so we do the following we start running
the execution
of uh trying to satisfy gm until
just before we reach a decision literal
where we would which would trigger a
fast back track
here we switched running the execution
e1
uh refuting f until it needs to restart
and because the variables are completely
distinct and the two
uh in f and gn there's no interaction
between these two things eb1 and e2
we run one more step of e2 on gn causing
a fast back track
this backtracks to a previous
decision level of e2 and thus
completely backtracks over all the
current uh decision levels of e1
so effectively backtracks e1 back to
decision level 0
carrying out a restart and then we
repeat this process
until eventually we get until
eventually eb1 shows that um
show well shows that the amp shows shows
the empty clause follows
so so of course there's also the id is
very nice there's some details here and
the
the how to choose gn um the construction
beam several wall use something base
that's basically counting up to two to
the n or counting up to two to the
well counting up to two to the two cn i
should say so they have a
assault they have a way of of searching
for the satisfying assignments gm that
requires basically searching through
exponentially many
partial assignments first before
reaching a satisfying assignment
the moral here though is fast
backtracking has a lot in common with
restarts
and um and i guess i question i could
throw out to
people here who are experts in this
stuff do people ever do
partial or maybe as a suggestion maybe
we should do partial restarts where
instead of restarting all the way back
to level zero
we just do sort of extra fast back
tracking beyond what would be needed by
clause learning
and um you know maybe there's some
middle ground of doing a partial restart
where so
don't go all the way back to level zero
but just go back further than you
usually would and
[Music]
i think that's the end of
part one so it's a good breakdown
questions and there's
uh yeah otherwise it's a good
a good break place so shall we uh
just say let's have i know
five ish or
five seven minute break uh which
means let's reconvene
by 9
9 43 is that a good
time uh berkeley time
so okay something 43 sounds good
yeah wherever you are 43
or 13 depending on what your time zone
is unless you're in i guess unless
you're in what newfoundland where you
have half hour
or india or india or india okay
okay and i guess you need to set up
questions
oh yeah
and if you have questions there are some
more questions on the chat
okay let me just ask is there a way to
get the
chat window as a text file after we're
done
well i'll try to get you one okay
because there should be a chat log
stored right someplace but okay
there's a lot of citations here i'd love
to have when i'm done
there is a question here from stefan
gawked
do you know if there's a way to force a
sat solver in doing only regular
resolution but going beyond
tree-like resolution um
see i mean
so if you if you don't go so i guess if
you don't do restarts
well so okay
so so i mentioned pool resolution where
you do a regular traversal
right but you're asking for something
stronger
um
so i wonder how that relates to my
question about the alternate
um well
well the trouble would be to get a stat
solver to give a refutation that uses
only
regular resolution you'd have to
restrict when learned clauses could be
used
um
by the way um yeah
uh
maybe it's a maybe a relevant comment
here is we do have
exponential or bounds on regular
resolution so there are principles like
the stone tautologies for instance
as well as other other tatologies that
require exponential length regular
resolution
um this is from the paper
electrovich johansson
potassium part um but these things do
have polynomial size pool resolution
uh refutations and polynomial size
resolution
refutations so regularization we do know
the separations there
um but i wouldn't know restricting a sat
solver to do only regular resolution
sounds like a pretty strong restriction
so oh so the question here i mean asked
is pool resolution
separated from uh general resolutions
the answer is no
um i skipped that topping my talk but
there's been
several candidates i just mentioned to
stefan of
formulas that were known to be
require exponential length regular
resolution and for a while they were
sort of the prime candidates
for conjecturing the pool resolution
might require
exponential length but all those
candidates have now
succumbed um
papers of myself and co-authors
including bonnet johansson
co-letic things like the stone
tautologies and so on have all been
shown to have
polynomial size pool resolution
refutations
so we don't have any good candidates for
separating pool resolution from general
resolution
okay i guess um
shall we restart are people back from
the break
yes
okay restart sounds like a good word
here okay
so this is sort of restart the second
part will not depend on the first part
at all
so not even any learned clauses being
carried forward
so here's a hierarchy of proof systems
um
and actually let me just go ahead and
show the second one as well with some
algebraic and semi-algebraic proof
systems added in
so we've got here dpl
regular resolution cdcl without restarts
uh cdcl with restarts and red resolution
or equivalent
um most of these arrows are known not to
reverse but i guess
let me see put red dots these ones with
red dots
it's open whether or not the simulation
goes the other way as well
constant depth fragile i'll talk about a
bit later on this is with constant
alternations of hands and ors constant
depth orega with
mod p axioms or mod p principles
constant depth fragment with mod p gates
uh
fragrant with counting gates uh full
fraga extender frag and then there's
well let's go over to the algebraic side
of things there's the null stalin zots
and the
polynomial calculus i defined in the
earlier
uh pre-recorded videos and i'll define
them again here
and then there's shearly atoms and sum
of squares which are semi-algebraic
systems
and those are simulated by fraga and
finally there's one more algebraic
proof system uh with an asterisk on it
for ideal proof system it's not quite a
proper proof system but we'll talk about
that okay
and let me see what's known here oh this
dashed line this dashed line the things
below the dashed line
are known to be are known to
not be uh polynomially bounded in that
there are tautologies that require
long proofs so exponentially long proof
so particularly the ones on the left
hand side
we have examples of tautologies which
require exponentially long proofs in
these systems
on the right hand side i guess the same
is true although usually people there
measure the degree
the degree of a proof rather than the
size of a proof
above the dashed line it's open possibly
once you get constant fragment with mod
p gates
it has polynomial length proofs of all
tautologies
um open question right it seems unlikely
um
after i drew this i was thinking about
um this dashed line is the theory line
so this is the theory line the theory
line meaning where
we don't have exponential or bounds on
there's also the sort of practice line
so the practice line would be where we
actually search for proofs
so if i was going to draw the practice
line
i would draw it here
right and so the things below the red
line
are things that people do search for
proofs maybe i should have drawn it
possibly i should have drawn it not
including resolution just this way right
although they're equivalent um in other
words the
theories like cdcl plus restarts are
below the practice line so they're
things that we actually use when we're
searching for proofs
sum of squares people actually used to
search for proofs
um so uh the practice line and the
theory line don't quite
align as it were but uh it's still
interesting in this
i want to talk here so what i want to do
for this part of the talk is
give the definitions of the algebraic
and the semi-algebraic proof systems i'm
not going to do any much more than that
um i should i should admit i'm not
you know completely up to date on the
literature in these areas so
for me it's also learning experience to
talk about them so
um so that's good but uh i thought i
didn't do a very good job of
discussing the semi i didn't discuss the
semi-auto algebraic systems all in
pre-recorded
videos i want to at least cover those so
let me give those definitions
so for the null stellenzos and the
polynomial calculus
these are algebraic proof systems we're
going to work over a field
possibly a a a finite field
we have variables uh
x1 x2 are they're viewed as boolean
variables but now we let them take on
values 0 and 1
where 0 is identified with true and 1 is
identified with false
and then a polynomial in general was
identified with the assertion that f
equals zero so for example a clause
x or y-bar or z can be expressed with a
polynomial
one minus x times y times one minus z
meaning that equals zero right so either
x equals one or y equals zero or z
equals one
right so any clause can easily be
written
as a polynomial if the clause is a three
set they're
following along degree three and so on
an algebraic refutation
of a set of polynomials f sub j
shows the fjs cannot simultaneously be
given a value zero
by finding or at least proving that
there exists
a polynomial identity of the following
form you take the sum
of f over j of fj
times gj plus the sum over i
of x i squared minus x i times h i
and that should be equal as a polynomial
identity to the polynomial one
so if you have this equality holding
it's pretty clear you can't set the
fjs all equal to zero
at least not for boolean values for zero
for x for the x i so boolean values
zero one values will make the term
x i squared minus x i equal to zero if
the fjs are also equal to zero
we have things times zero can't sum up
to equal one right
so this refutes the possibility that you
can set all these polynomials
simultaneous to zero for boolean inputs
and this as i've written here just is a
null stellenzos refutation
um the north shell and sauce reputation
just explicitly write out the
polynomials gj and hi
that makes this a polynomial identity so
i say write it out i mean write it out
as a sum of a solve
a sum of monomials and then you can
easily carry out the multiplication
check that it's a polynomial identity
equal to one
the this is a so-called static proof
system
uh static because you write it's just
the lines
the proof is just a single line there's
no inferences um
you just write out the equality and
which can be checked
polynomial calculus is what's called a
dynamic proof system but it can prove
the same things
so it uses inference steps the initial
formulas are the fj's and the
x i squared minus x i's and the
inference rules are addition and
multiplication
from if you inferred f and g and think
of that meaning you've inferred f equals
zero and for
g equals zero you can infer f plus g
and if you've inferred f think of that
as referring f equals zero
you can infer f times g
and so it should be clear that the
polynomial calculus can prove
one equals zero if only if the null
stellar zones can prove one equals zero
but the polynomial calculus proofs can
be
shorter or have lower degree than the
north stellenson systems because uh
because you have cancellation that
occurs along the way
so this is the definition of the shell
and zones in the polynomial calculus
these are first two algebraic systems
um
there's also the semi-algebraic systems
here we there's sha there's shearly
atoms and sum of squares
so here we work in an ordered field uh
variables x1 x2 etc are still zero one
valued
uh we identify zero with true one with
false
we now work with inequalities not so
instead of working with
equalities like f equals zero we work
with inequalities f greater than or
equal to zero
so for example clause x or not y
or z this can be expressed with x minus
y plus z
greater than or equal to zero so
um so or x plus one minus y plus z
greater than or equal to one right and
then a set of clauses
gamma can be turned into a set
of polynomial inequalities of the form
f j greater than equal to zero and now
the equalities we had on x
i squared minus x i equals zero become
two of them that
x i squared minus x i is greater than
equal to zero and x
i minus x i squared is greater than
equal to zero
um sometimes people leave this in other
versions of the system
as just equal zero and then a
semi-algebraic refutation of gamma
is shows or proves that there exists a
polynomial
identity of the form summation over k
of pk times rk equals -1 so the pks are
the
all of the fj's x i squareds and
x i x i squared minus x i's and the x
i's minus x i squared
and the r k's are polynomials which are
known to be non-negative for boolean
inputs
now that there'll be different choices
for the share of the atoms the sum of
squares
so clearly if you have a bunch of things
that are so the pks
are assuming they're all non-negative
and the rks are known to be non
not non-negative well if we take a
product of two non-negative things it's
not negative so the sum is still not
non-negative
so it can't equal minus one so this
refutes the possibility that you've
got boolean inputs that make all the fjs
non-negative
and then the cheryl lee adams refutation
this is a static version of it
is just basically give a polynomial
identity of that form summation over k p
k times r k equals minus one
where the r k's um
oh paul's got a correction for me i
might need one of the p
k's to be one ah i don't think i
realized that
so let me let me correct that here so
paul is suggesting
that i might need one here um
okay i'll i'll believe paul that sounds
right any okay
uh it definitely works it's still a
reputation
okay uh
huh okay good so thank you please
please correct me whenever i say
something false that's very very
important
so the shirley adams reputation system
this is the static version of it it's
also formulated in the dynamic version
times
gives a poem gives a poem identity well
now the rk's are equal to
terms of the form um
x i or products of things the form x i
and one minus x i so x i is greater than
equal to zero
because it's either zero one and one
minus x i is greater than equal to zero
so for instance r k could be one minus x
one times x two times one minus x three
uh as a product of non-negative things
it's still non-negative and sometimes i
guess this is called
non-negative winter and so this would be
a shearly
adams refutation system the sum of
squares refutation system uses the rk is
equal to squares
so you have rk has the form sk squared
for some
some polynomial sk um
and otherwise it's the same conceptually
the same so you can sh
it's fairly easy to see the sum of
squares is
more powerful than shearly atoms you can
get these
non-negative puentas from you can
express them
of sum of squares well using the fact
that we've got the
the pks include the x i
squared minus x i's and the x size minus
x i squared
we can write any non-negative punta as a
sum of squares
modulo being able to multiply by those
items
and so um so the sum of squares is
strictly more powerful as it turns out
than shirley adams
and both systems so okay yeah good so
that's the basic definitions there
there's a i didn't want to get into
theorems here
as i said um i could certainly quote
them but uh you know it's sort of
getting hopefully other people will talk
about this future
later on in the quarter and later on in
the term um
but at least wanted to get the
definitions out there um
one last system is a very powerful
system you know
remember recall was up at the top of the
slides above
the extended fraga is the ideal proof
system this is due to
grow chao and potassium a few years ago
somewhere in the last three or four
years is the ideal
proof system um again now we're back to
an
algebraic system uh we work in a field
we identify
zero with true and one with false uh
we let fis the f i's be a set of
polynomials expressing
that uh some set of clauses
or sorry expressing the clauses in a set
here uh
back to algebraic so f i equals zero
expresses the condition that the i
clause is true and now our pks range
again over the fis
and the x i squared minus x i i guess i
should not need one here and the
ideal proof system then it's given by a
single algebraic circuit
which has two kinds of variables
let's call the circuit c of c of uv
and there's a vector of variables u of
vector variables v
an algebraic circuit means an algebraic
formula but written in dag form
circuit form so that the two identities
hold first of all c of u v
equals zero for variables u and v
and then if we substitute in the
polynomials p for the v's
c of u p equals one um
so obviously
if these both hold we can't these can't
both hold if the p's can be set
simultaneously equal to zero
um so that would serve as a refutation
for the
f's i's being true over boolean
variables
uh one one caveat here is that the ideal
proof system is not
a cook recall proof system as i defined
it in the
uh recorded videos uh one crucial
property of proofs
is that you should be able to check in
polynomial time whether a proof is a
valid proof
and so but testing these identities for
ac
c of uv equals zero or c of up equals
one we
is done the best algorithms known are
randomized polynomial time
so it's uh it's sort of morally approved
system but it's not
literally speaking a quick recall-proof
system
okay
okay um so i just wanted to get these
definitions out here in particular our
ideal proof system is extremely strong
and these systems along with cutting
planes are
back to my earlier picture here
i was talking about systems below the
lines and so i sort of left cutting
planes
out of the pictures below the lines just
because it didn't fit in
quite so smoothly with the other two
topics here but
cutting planes of course is doing sums
right so
uh it it would sit it had it's somewhat
akin to
the the mod p stuff that i'm talking
about over here but it would also be
here of course below the line is a
system that's heavily used
for um
proof search i guess i should add also i
left off here because it'd be messy
there should be an arrow from shirley
adams to route to resolution because
shirley adams simulates resolution
as well as polynomial calculus simulates
resolution
okay
so that was everything i had to say i
just wanted to give the definitions here
if any experts want to speak up and add
something otherwise i'll go on to
part three of the talk but maybe just
pause here for questions or comments
sam uh a couple of quick questions
so um there have been this newer style
of
proof system this interference
interference-based proof systems um and
you have a couple of papers on those
so where would those proof systems fit
in sorry i didn't quit
the interference-based proof systems
like one introduced by mariahle
uh where you uh
had these redundancy propagation clauses
and and so on
uh oh okay okay sure so you're talking
about the the
the the draft proof systems and so forth
yes
so this is so those um
so those are sitting i mean in the full
form they can simulate extended fraga
right so up here
but that's only if you if you have the
new variable rule though if you have the
new variables right so this would be
d-wrap with new variables right but if
you don't allow new variables
um we have
we have a lot of so they're all
equivalent um
and um
depending on the details some of them
live above the bottom line but most of
them
some some of them live below the dotted
line we have exponential lower bounds
under some restrictions
but most of them live up here somewhere
above the dotted line and
um as far as i know they don't simulate
something like constant deprego so they
would sit off to the side
okay right
so so on news asked us the choice of
field make a difference the power of
north shore and zot's proof systems
absolutely yes uh i guess that would
follow from old paper of
beam and pogba so cry chick woodlock and
woods
that mill stellenzon's mod p and we'll
stall and slots mod q
are different they don't they don't
simulate each other um say let's for
simplicity take p and q to be
distinct primes um
and paul's mentioning dynamic sos
and positive stella and zots so let me
see
is positive telling zotz a um
a synonym for dynamic sos dynamic
version of sos
this was the s sum of square systems i
think was first defined as
in the terminology positive shell and
thoughts maybe by gregoria
a little bit vague on that now um
positive stones that's calculus is the
term okay
no positive stellar thoughts okay
okay good so yeah so there's a there's a
variety of systems out there
um and i think pause positive stellenzos
was one of the first forms
proposed
okay so i wanted to end with just
mentioning a two of
my sort of favorite and also
long-standing open problems at the
frontier of
proof complexity which was um put this
up here
basically involves you know
things uh here
constant depth fragile with mod gates i
can't i'm trying to draw there and i
can't do it let me see
here but also just playing constant
depth
there's a couple open questions that are
long-standing
just want to mention so first of all the
constant depth fraga
separations so let me remind you with
the formula of the depth of a
propositional formula so here we've got
a formula over the connectives ands and
ors and nots
um we're not dealing with clauses
anymore they're general propositional
formulas
and that we can use day morgan's laws to
push the negations down to the atoms
and then the depth of a formula is the
number of alternating blocks of ands and
ors
on any or the maximum number of all
alternating blocks of answer orders on
any path in the proof tree
and a depth d fraga proof means a fragra
proof in which all
formulas have a depth d and if you
missed my pre-recorded lectures a
prager proof means an ordinary
propositional proof system based on
modus ponens
um if you want to be elegant about it
you probably put it in the sequent
calculus version but
everything i say here is vague enough
they'll also fit for a system that uses
modus ponens and then there was a
really great set of results
uh in the late 80s and early 90s about x
they gave exponential lower bounds for
constant depth fragrance proof so the
pigeon principle
um i thai gave some super polynomial
lower bounds and then improved to
exponential by
authors uh well that's beam and pogliazo
cryocheck potassium woodlock and woods
92
and split into separate papers in 93 and
95.
and there's also known some conditional
non-automatizability and non-craig
interpret
in interpretation interpolation results
for constant that fraga based on the
hardness of the diffie-hellman crypto
system
so we have lower bounds for constant
depth fragra proofs
but the question is can we separate
depth d
from depth d plus one fragment proofs
and
when refuting sets of clauses
so the idea is you're given a set of
clauses think of these as just being a
bunch of you know
a set of ores a set of clauses you're
trying to
derive falsity from them in a depth d
figure proof
do you get substantial improvement if
you go from depth d to def d plus one
faker proofs in terms of proof length
so the best result is that um
due to cryocheck uh
building on earlier work that basically
i would say prove most of it anyway by
impoveliyatso and cryocheck
giving a super polynomial separation for
depth d plus one versus depth d
um based on the pigeon principle in fact
and we also know that casa de fraga you
can think of
resolution as being a kind of depth one
system again to be elegant about this
you might go to the sequent calculus
and we do know that costa fraga has
exponential speed up over
as resolution for the week for the weak
pigeon principle
but what about the higher values of d
this seems to be
beyond the super polynomial um
separation they're completely open can
we give instead an x
an exponential separation and part of
the reason this is a
tantalizing problem is from hostile
switching results
we know that the expressibility of depth
d plus one formulas is much better
or can be much better than the
expressibility of deaf d formulas
there's things that require that have
short or small def t plus one form
formulas but require exponential size
def
d for formulas so depth d plus one fraga
can have substantially more expressive
power than that defrag in terms of the
formulas it can write out in the proof
but that doesn't translate to a
separation of the proof systems so the
question would be for
refuting sets of clauses does depth d
plus one very good give you a
good speed a large speed up over death d
so that was my first open question uh
and again part of the reason
it's so tantalizing is we have lower
bounds on
expressibility in the system that
somehow doesn't translate into lower
bounds on
proof complexity
and the second open question has a
similar feature
the mod p fraga systems so there's
two ways to talk about mod p fragrance
systems so here i want to
focus on the version with gates we fix
the prime p
single prime p a mod p gate is an
unbounded fan in boolean connective
it outputs one if and only the number of
true inputs is zero mod p
and then the open problem is to give
exponential lower bounds on depth d
figure proofs over the propositional
language with not
or and and the mod p gates and we can
use notation ac zero
of of mod p fraga for this system
um so again this is tantalizing because
by the results of rasborov and spalensky
we know exponential lower bounds for
expressibility
of ac0p circuits
in particular for the counting mod q can
require exponential size so to make a
bound to depth circuit with parity gates
and or gates
that counts mod q can require x
exponential size and this suggests the
following that the
ac 0 of parity p fragra proofs
for the mod q counting principle
might require exponential size but um
but we don't know that right so um but
it's again
tantalizing because we don't we just
don't we have expressibility lower
bounds we don't have proof complexity
lower bounds
i can give you the mod q counting
principle here
which many of you heard of the parity
principle the mod q counting principle
just generalizes this in sort of the
maybe the obvious way uh for
an integer n not a multiple of q the mod
q
counting principle expresses there's no
partition of a set of size n
into sets of size q so partition means
that
you have sets of size q whose disjoint
union is all of n
and this is expressed with variables x
sub s for s a subset of size
q x of s means that the subset
s is in the partition and the clause is
we have the or
over x of s's such as i's and s just to
say that each eye
is covered by the partition and then we
have that
not excess or not xs prime for each
part each of sets of each pair of sets
s and s prime of size q whose
intersection
is strictly between 0 and q so this is
the
mod q counting principle on an earlier
slide i have the
uh constant fraga with mod q
axioms or my p axis i call it there and
that just means
uh constant death fragrance where we
take all instances of the mod q
principle and add them in as axioms
uh i need to collect it right on the
slide here and so
we do have separations between the
constant depth fraga with mod p counting
axioms
and the mod q constant death ray of
with counting axioms let me say it again
we have separation constant fragment
with mod p counting axioms
and cost of that fray with mod q
counting axioms so we can separate
and give x exponential or bounds for the
systems that take the mod q
counting principles as axioms and all
instances of them
instances of them but we don't have
lower bounds
when we take the mod p gates and add
them into the language
even with restriction to constant depth
so again this is
tantalizing or frustrating because we
ought to be able to give these kind of
lower bounds based on expressibility
conditions but we haven't been able to
so some is it true that
the the depth hierarchy here collapses
right in the mod q
fragrance systems um
not that i know of isn't that your
result i mean
for abundant arithmetic with
with modular gates uh
isn't it sorry i'm sorry i i guess it
collapsed i thought you meant separates
yes it does it does collapse
to quasi-polynomial size right um
yeah yeah is it for clauses or is it for
higher depth formulas
um so this is the this is essentially
the atos
theorem yeah you're right it's in a
paper of mine um
so we do get
so yeah so we so we do get the hierarchy
collapses for the mod p
yeah good yeah yes that's correct okay
okay so one question that could connect
to your other
open problem is
whether you can have this collapse when
you have also
when you don't have gates but you have
the principle
suppose you have mounted that fragra
with the
mod q principle or
does that collapse to some fixed depth
ah i definitely do not know of any
result of that kind
um i mean the collapse seems to depend
pretty heavily on having the gate in the
language
right but i guess it's possible that the
collapse could occur
anyway with the i mean with the gate
with the axioms only but the no
the known results depend very heavily on
having the gauge in the language
uh let me before you ask more questions
let me get to my thank you slide
so so good yeah thank you so much
and this was really cool
thank you and so
more questions comments suggestions
so one thing is it's a comment at one
point
it was asked whether uh cdcl
uh without restart is automatable
right so you ask this question and
so the comment i wanted to make is that
because it simulates regular resolution
right and regular resolution is not
automatable in terms of resolution
then i think it follows that it's not
automatically unless p equals lb
okay so because the non-automatability
results
they are stronger than what they are
stated they are stated for resolution
but they actually hold even for regular
resolution okay
this was an observation of uh susannah
and so this is it should then follow
that uh
cdcl without restarts it's not
automatically
okay so does this also imply that uh
constant depth fraga is not automatic
automatizable
no that we don't know yet because
the lower bound is only for resolution
or now we also know for polynomial
calculus and
and that's it polynomial calculus and
cutting planes but
not the lower bound is not known
beyond in the case of the so because the
non-automatability result
requires an upper bound and a lower
bound and the lower bound is known for
resolution
cutting planes and polynomial calculus
but not for higher depth
free right okay yeah just for my
question of context it's known that
as i mentioned if if tiffy hellman is is
uh
is hard then it's not on automatizable
but it'd be nice to get it
unconditionally
right there would always be a condition
but
well yeah but my advice for you sorry
goodnight on the weakest possible
position
p not equal np right so
there might might not always be may we
solve these questions someday
you can be optimistic
i would have another question
so you talked about the definite
resolution can simulate
external flag and therefore also fragile
but is there also anything known if we
limit the number of extension variables
so if you don't allow an arbitrary
number of extension variables but say
like
logarithmic and the number of variables
of the formula or something
oh uh that should be um so you could i
mean you might also look at the
the amount which the extension variables
are are nested right in terms of using
each other
so if you have um yeah so if you have a
if they're nested to depth d you could
and the formulas they abbreviate are all
size
n you could expand the
variables introduced by extension
working in fragus system you could just
expand the definitions
and how each red resolution variable
could be replaced by a formula of size
n to the d where d is this is in
fraga an extended fragrance extended
resolution
um you could
if you just bound the depth you would be
getting something like constant fragra
or something like that yeah
um just constant number
my feeling is if you literally allowed
my expectation is if you allowed only
d for constant d many of extension rules
that you probably wouldn't get super
polynomial speed up but i don't have a
proof at my fingertips though let me say
that so
yeah that seems like a pretty strong
restriction
thanks yeah okay
um anybody questions actually um
i have a question so you you had one
example of
a proof where you have effectively
a simulation rather than the standard p
simulation i was wondering what are the
other examples
and would you consider things like that
um
changing bases in nostalgia that can
take you from having exponential to
polynomial size
proof um
so i missed the very last part changing
basis
uh so those uh recent results
um an observation of russell
and student and also several other
people that
if you uh represent i think cycling
tautology
in base one minus one versus
zero ones then you get polynomial size
rather than exponential size nostalgia
that's proof
is this also an example of effective
simulation
and so what would be other examples
well i mean the thing about this example
russell and co-authors is that's very
specialized to the
to scientologies so
um but yeah in general
in general you want to have some sort of
for effective p simulation you want to
have a translation that works for any
formula
and actually if you go back to robert
recal's thesis
he defined p simulation there but if you
look at it it's really more like
effective pcm simulation than peace than
simulation
um than than p simulation he was worried
about
translating between systems over
different languages
so for instance what if you put a parity
in in
a binary paragraph connected in the
language
how would you simulate that with a proof
system that doesn't allow the binary
connected you can't even express the
formula you're proving
so as i recall it it's been a long time
scholarships thesis
he basically said well any sort of
translation
uh is okay you take a you have a
an initial proof system an initial
formula
you transform the formula by some
polynomial time process
you take a proof in the target proof
system and you transform it back by
pulling the time process and it gives
you a proof in the first system
and he was again my it's been a long
time since i actually read it carefully
but my recollection is he was a little
vague about what kind of transformations
were okay and he said clearly
i think he didn't really need to do
counter-intuitive
translations but that was his definition
as i recall if i recall correctly
so some version of effective p
simulation at least
not quite in the term in the modern
terms exists already in
ice israel's thesis oh nice
thank you i should look at it
um i'm not sure i answered your question
though so
you did you told me where to look for
more of this
thank you uh more questions comments
um sam i i think you may have addressed
this
earlier um you had a proof system with
axioms in it
in addition to gates uh the gay
um proof system how are the axioms
represented
okay yeah i have not to put a slide in
about that and somehow i neglected to um
so what basically we have these
we're working in a phryga system right
right and so the phraga system would
have an axiom that takes the
takes the takes the dnf formulas the
negation of the set of clauses for the
mod q counting principle
and we then allow substituting any
any formulas for the variables x sub x
sub s
so we've got the math mod q counting
principle as stated here becomes a dnf
formula with variables x sub s
and then we allow any choice formulas
replacing the x sub
s and that becomes a so-called instance
a substitution instance of the mod q
counting principle and we take that as
an additional axiom
it's still subjective in a constant
depth version of the system we're still
subject to
the depth restrictions after we do the
substitution
and this was uh let me see this is done
it's known that
as i mentioned the mod q counting axioms
and the mod p counting axioms
over constant give you are not don't
don't
don't simulate each other this is due to
eye thai
i want to say late 80s um and then
another paper of um
oh it's in the bik w paper uh
uh beam and pogba also cry check put
like woods i guess paper um do it from
the point of view of noel stellenzotz
um and i if i recall correctly they only
get super polynomial separation uh
paul's online or might still be online i
don't think they get an
exponential separation between these
systems so that
might be worth following up on whether
there's still open question here about
about exponential separations
ah paul as reese has shown exponential
separations okay
good so scratch my last comment and
cite reese instead that's uh so sworn
reese
okay
and paul beam reese oh okay yeah my eyes
are going
so so uh paul beam and uh
and so orbeez okay
okay um i don't know if people have more
questions but let me
just say uh would you have time to hang
out and gather town after that stuff
so let me just post the link to gather
down
so that after we are out of zoom you
could hang out there
and maybe talk more and ask more
questions if someone's there
but in the meantime if you think of more
questions
please
so let me suggest uh oh oh me i'm not
sure i'll pronounce your name if you
send me a chat
discussion i can post it on my webpage
for this talk if people want to be able
to access the text of the chat yeah i'll
do that
okay good okay thanks
okay so if there are no more questions
so thank you so much sam for the
wonderful talk and make sure to look at
the pre-recorded videos they're great
too and cover
ton of ground and uh shall we
retire to the gutter town thank you so
much sam
for the wonderful talk to get everybody
excited
thank you it's great to have a chance to
talk
okay
you